hey everybody welcome back to the
Japanese garden in this episode I am
finally building the first actual
building of this series after doing a
lot of foliage terraforming and rock
work of course and it's honestly not
just about the aesthetics it'll be quite
a simple Japanese tea building which you
commonly see in these kinds of parks
it's also something that is I think
quite important to have for your guests
in these kinds of parks for any kind of
facilities mostly eating food and
drinking tea I'll explain a little bit
more about that along the way but first
I'm procrastinating a little bit here by
working on the rockwork and foliage in
this area because this will be the area
where the tea house is gonna be built in
the upper left corner of the screen
right now and I wanted to make sure that
at least the surrounding area of the tea
house was a little bit done just so that
at the end of building the tea house and
kind of along the way I can kind of tell
what the context of the building is
gonna be because one thing that I do
feel with these Japanese kinds of tea
houses and actually yeah let's just get
right into the building itself I was
gonna talk about that later in the video
but it might just make sense to segue
into it now
the thing about these houses is that
they're quite small and they're quite
simple and one of the biggest
distinctions between for instance a
Chinese garden and a Japanese conan' is
that we're a Chinese garden is very much
centered around the buildings and the
buildings are really a large focus of
the garden and you're supposed to look
at the gun and from the perspective of
building these Japanese types of gardens
and especially this kind of garden where
it's a strolling garden or a garden
around the lake it's something that is
supposed to be looked at from different
perspectives you're just supposed to
discover the different views of the
garden as you walk through it and it's
not necessarily supposed to be seen from
inside a building so these buildings
aren't really so important because they
they're not really the focus of the
garden and if anything they're just
something to gawk at something to be
part of the sightlines and I suppose in
a way kind of be the wienies of these
gardens if you want to put it in theme
park terms but it's it's not so much a
focus it's
just to be part of the landscape to
establish this natural landscape and so
I think what you'll see with a lot of
these small tea houses but also other
kinds of buildings in Japanese gardens
is that they tend to do what a lot of
traditional Japanese buildings tend to
do and rather than standing out they
kind of blend in with nature there might
be a few trees in front of the building
or it's just kind of hidden for instance
there there's this little teahouse in
the rakubian garden which is underneath
these big trees which makes it really
charming especially when it's dark and
you can just see the lights in the
distance of the forest but it's not
really a center point of the garden per
se it's just kind of part of the view
and that's also why the building in this
episode will be pretty simple and why
honestly it won't take that much time to
build either and why the focus is still
kind of on doing the foliage and
everything and when it comes to this
area over here in the entrance I just
wanted to make sure to fill this in as
well in this episode because so far I
feel like all of the foliage in the
garden has been of the the very not so
dense variety where it's just manicured
bushes and strategically placed Japanese
pine trees but in a lot of gardens
you'll also find some parts of the
garden where you really have narrow
paths walking through forests with very
dense foliage as well so that's what
this part and hopefully also the other
part of the garden will be more like I
imagine it'll be nice because this is
the entrance of the garden at least one
of the two entrance I think it'll be
nice to make sure that the entrance
areas are one of these more dense
foliage parts so you come into the into
the garden itself and you don't really
see the center point with the gone in
itself yet so you don't see the lake yet
you just have some narrow paths that
wind through a forest so you kind of
have a section of the garden to kind of
be immersed inside gone in a little bit
and only after you've turned a few
corners through this dense forest do you
kind of see the lake opening up in the
distance at least that's what I found
happens with a lot of the gardens in
real life in Japan as well to take the
example of the cookie and gone and again
there's also this little area where
there's a few small buildings where you
enter the garden there's a large cherry
tree but you don't see the lake yet
that's at the center of the gun and that
one really only appears once you
actually go further into the garden
itself
so yeah there's that and besides I did
want to try and get more variety into
this garden because if it was just you
know those those low-density trees and
manicured bushes everywhere it would get
repetitive really quickly so that's a
little bit of the rationale behind how
I'm making this garden just realized
that as with a lot of videos about a
certain topic you should not do drinking
game with me saying the word garden I'll
try it over it I'll try to overuse it a
little bit less in the rest of this
video but yeah it's not much that you
can do about it that's the topic of this
video in the end something that I also
can't really avoid is doing all of these
little fences it's obviously something
that takes quite a bit of time and it's
not the most interesting to do but it's
something which I thought was quite a
big part of these gardens they kind of
demarcate that you maybe you shouldn't
be walking on the grass in these places
and just kind of stay on the path itself
and I found a lot of these very low tiny
wooden fences of different varieties in
the gardens in Tokyo and even if they
don't really stick out so much it's
something that you don't really notice
that much until you really pay attention
to it I still think it's an important
part of the garden never mind that the
pots in planet coaster don't have any
curbs and I think that the look of a
curbless path without any fences or
curbs is a little bit weird but I think
that placing these little fences in
there looks a tiny bit better than just
using the planet coaster curbs what I
also have found pretty interesting about
these is basically 99% of that video
which I did make about Japanese gardens
I was using these little wooden posts
and fences on the side of the path to
attach my camera onto which is pretty
handy you can actually get some really
cool views who the gone into with these
things and they're a perfect thing to
attach your gorilla pod to so that's
pretty neat but that's not what they're
really intended for
there are definitely some areas by the
way where you can walk on the grass like
some of the areas where I left the
little fence open and put like some
stepping stones or something up a hill
because that's something that I've seen
quite a few times in these gardens as
well anyway onto onto I suppose the main
dish of tonight
this is gonna be the tea house and I'll
be spending a lot of time honestly
making a pretty simple building just
because I wanted to get the composition
and the scale of it rights and because
of that it's it's doesn't use the actual
in-game roofs or well it uses an in-game
roof piece but not in a way that you
would use in-game roofs which is set at
a certain incline and it uses at many
points also windows for walls and stuff
like that just to make sure that
everything is slightly off grid and not
quite the way that you know walls and
roofs would be placed normally in planet
coaster because I was kind of very picky
about the the angles of the roofs and
the size of the building because that's
honestly the only way that I can make
this building stick out it's not gonna
be a very detailed building it's not
gonna be a very large building so I
wanted to make sure to get the size and
shape of the building as much as I
wanted to and now I have to say at this
point I took a lot of inspiration to the
point of pretty much honestly copying
the basic shape of the building from the
teahouse in kissimmee garden in Tokyo
and I definitely want to say that
because I feel like it's I I would be
very dishonest if I were just building
this and not mentioning when I took it
from because it's so heavily based on it
and honestly I didn't exactly know what
to do if I'd have to come up with my own
complete design for a Japanese teahouse
because I feel like I'd very quickly go
into territory that wouldn't be
realistic or that wouldn't be true to
the style so I was trying to play it
safe by basing it as much as I could on
a existing teahouse and I do have to say
that doesn't go too far beyond the roof
and the size of the structure because
it's really mostly the roof which I
based on the kyo SMAT house but still a
something that is really similar to it
only difference that I suppose I made on
a large scale is that I added another
wing to it on the right side and instead
of being a completely open tea house
because the one in kyo semicolon is more
or less almost a pavilion because the
entire thing is entirely open this thing
will have some railings on the sides but
also sliding walls so it's more of an
actual building I would say at least so
yeah it doesn't feature what a lot of
people tend to associate with Japanese
architecture and having those heavily
detailed roofs which curve upwards
toward the side and honestly those are
really just a minority of roofs in
Japanese architecture a lot of the times
there are much more simple and they're
really just straight roofs but there's
still very Japanese style to the way
that it's a a roof with a cable like
this yet with these cornered roofs on
the sides and the fact that there's two
different roofs stacked with the lower
one kind of sticking out and giving a
walkway along the weather so yeah
overall it's still a very Japanese shape
it's just not as heavily detailed as you
might see on some pagodas or temples or
stuff like that I mean realistically
this would also just be a tea house for
a little garden or a pretty lush garden
but it's just the tea house so I don't
think it would have to be quite that
expensive and a lot of my struggle hero
is trying to get the wooden posts and
all of the walls rights since everything
is slightly off-grid oh and off-grid and
also playing with textures was quite
important you can see me looking for the
right wooden texture and a few points in
this video just because when you've got
such a simple building especially when
you've got a very minimalistic building
I think it's it's a lot of the look of a
building is in the texture as well as
the shape and composition of it so I
just wanted to make sure that I got the
textures that I liked I wanted
everything to be a little bit rustic and
some of the wooden textures and planet
coaster
pretty bright and pretty new looking so
I I kind of messed about with a few
different textures there also sometimes
I still kind of have to discover the new
wooden texture that came out of the
adventure pack in the haunted the spooky
DLC I should say because I didn't play
that much with those definitely not in
this kind of theme and I never really
had a session where I explored all the
new pieces so sometimes it still kind of
need to get used to those oh yeah and
then there's of course the the wooden
planks on the side here making that very
typical fence shape where you have two
horizontal beams and then small vertical
beams as decoration in between that it's
a little bit decorative I suppose what
this building could have done with
something simpler but I think it looks
pretty neat on this and besides there's
not gonna be that much building there's
not gonna be that much detail on the
building otherwise because I ended up
removing a lot of detail in the end you
can see me adding a door here with these
window is looking paper slides as well
and I ended up removing those in the end
because it doesn't really make sense at
this point I was still thinking these
walls are just gonna be standard walls
they'll have windows and doors in them
but at some point I figured it might
actually be nicer to make it ease into
the sliding walls which you see in a lot
of traditional Japanese architecture so
every grid space is basically a wall
that you can slide in and out and with
that you can either close or open the
building so that's something which I'll
be doing with this later on and that's
why I'll be removing the door and the
windows at some point and the same goes
also for the little wing of the building
on the side here there isn't really too
much of a function to this part of the
building honestly because it doesn't
really need it size-wise these tea
houses are often really small but I
think it looks a little bit better and
it adds a bit of a counterweight to the
the main part of the building
so I like the addition of this so I
decided just to edit for looks in the
end the building is kind of for looks in
there anyway I'm obviously just
pretending that this is an actual tea
house
and that guests will be able to use this
and he'll that the walls can be sliding
but obviously none of this is actually
gonna happen this is planet coaster in
the end but yeah I think these tea
houses are quite nice unfortunately I
never actually did anything in any of
them I never actually bought something
in these tea houses but you will find
them in almost every Japanese garden
certainly if it's a strolling garden
around the lake and they tend to just
have some really basic services pretty
much all of them sell much the Japanese
green tea and also mochi which is those
rice cakes which honestly I find kind of
disappointing but I think I've made a
lot of people mad with that sort of
unpopular opinion but yeah green tea is
pretty awesome so I kind of regret not
ever getting any of that in one of these
tea houses but a lot of people just kind
of use these to sit down for a bit or
look out over the lake or whatever it's
a bit of the a bit of downtown hmm it's
a bit of downtime in your day if you're
visiting one of these gardens and
probably also a cool place to have an
actual tea ceremony so yeah that's why
this is here I don't know how many other
buildings I'll be ending to this garden
maybe like a toilet building or
something like that because actually a
lot of these things also have public
toilet buildings and usually you can go
to the toilet for free in these Gardens
because you have to pay entrance fee
which is still really low typical
entrance fee for Japanese gone it's like
two three or four dollars and you can
stay there pretty much the entire day so
that's pretty good and there's lots of
really good facilities in these as well
and they certainly don't try to rip you
off on anything the toilets are usually
free and getting to your candy is
usually pretty cheap as well you more or
less just pay for the garden to be well
maintained and preserved because these
things are really old and they are kind
of a cultural tradition that they're
still continuing
I know I've set this in the Japanese
garden video about Tokyo but a lot of
these are really some of the only
remaining traditional old landscapes
that you can find in the mostly modern
cities of Japan because a lot of the old
buildings have been the mall
or lost in fires or Wars or whatever and
these gardens are pretty much in the
original States that they were designed
in hundreds of years ago so that is kind
of the what attracts people to them and
besides they're also kind of a similar
thing to parks in that they have a
public function of just being a place to
relax or cool down or escape from hectic
city life or whatever so obviously they
should be pretty cheap in easily
accessible
it does strike me though that these
gardens are kind of different than your
typical Park Inn that people really only
go to these gardens to look at them and
sure - it's a sort of relaxing thing but
it's not the same thing as when you go
to like Hyde Park to play frisbee or to
go cycling or running or whatever really
these gardens are typically pretty quiet
and really people just go here to take
pictures just enjoy the view or
something like that and I guess in that
sense it is different from just going to
a typical Park you're usually not gonna
have a standard picnic in here which is
interesting because hundreds of years
ago these were very often made for
families to have events in and
festivities or even hunt or whatever and
nowadays they're really almost like an
open-air museum in a sense not quite but
it's I feel like it's somewhere in
between that and an actual park because
if you do go to Japanese cities they'll
have western-style parks as well so this
really kind of feels a unique role in
that now here's a little bit of foliage
which is a little bit more experimental
I wanted to try and make one of these
hills which is completely filled by
shrubbery not entirely sure how well
it's gonna work out but I think the next
episode will be an important point to
judge that because in the next episode
I'm gonna try to make the path to go to
the top of this mountain for a good view
of the rest of this garden so yeah
thanks for watching guys and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
you